welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 5 which confirmed my
underworld theory but damn you hate to
be right if it means death by sand let's
break down this heartbreaking and
mind-blowing episode shot by shot for
all the details that you might have
missed and you can support new rock
stars by checking out our tomb of the
moon god shirt we're almost run out of
these over at newarkstarsmerch.com
getting this shirt will unlock the added
option to write in a custom shout out
that will appear at the bottom of our
moon night after shows so we open in the
cave as we hear mark's brother randall
shouting
now randall is the name of mark's
brother in the comics goes on to carry
the monikers of hatchet man and shadow
knight but i'm not here then mark's
mother snaps at him this is oh
and don't forget uncle frank look what
you did you little jerk now multiple
shots earlier this season focused on
close-ups of dry sand of course
foreshadowing the sands they would
return to this season but now in this
episode steven's corporeal fate and
since those sand dunes are depicted as
ocean waves that the boat passes through
the drowning of randall foreshadows the
drowning of mark's second brother that
he created to help cope with the trauma
of losing the first then we cut to this
goddess of motherhood screaming which
was directly from mark's screaming
mother from the mother mark feared to a
physically fearsome mother that actually
ends up being the nurturing mother that
they really need then to harrow's office
where he has fresh wounds on his nose
that were not there at the end of
episode 4. now later harrow does deny
sedating him so there is definitely off
the books violence with the orderlies
here but notice that bandage now mark
does have one of these when he talks to
konshu in the comics that this is based
on but this is also the kind of bandage
that you would see on a boxer's broken
nose and mark in the comics was also a
boxer and i bring all this up because
there is still the unseen jake lockley
altar the fiercest of the three we think
of the sarcophagus rattling it like a
boxer itching to get into the ring but
is he unseen because this altar in this
scene seems way more tense and way more
confused whenever harrow calls him mark
and oscar isaac is definitely making
different vocal choices here you're not
a doctor i always pay you a lot of money
in this place you know you're really
good and you must pay a lot of money in
this place i'm sorry look this episode
started from the low angle point of view
of that mom just before she was going to
hit him which might mean that in
addition to creating the altar of steven
grant on that day they also might have
created the altar of jake lockley in
that moment to actually take the abuse
which might have led to jake's extreme
violence so in total jake to take the
punches steven to think he had a loving
mum and mark to live with the guilt of
it all so within the subjective
afterlife aboard this ship mark's
organizing principal also created this
inner office to represent his self-doubt
so it may be jake in here and either way
jake is left in this psych ward meaning
he still has a chance to reconnect with
konshu to rescue the others then again
in the next scene mark retains what
heroes said about organizing principles
so it's not totally clear hey by the way
new rockstars is launching a new daily
live stream starting monday called the
break room where those yuccos down at
new rockstars hq are gonna react to
these boss hot takes while interacting
with you live keep an eye out for it
it's gonna be fun harrow says your brain
is a pendulum swinging between a very
difficult reality that you are my
patient here at putnam medical facility
in chicago illinois and
a reassuring fantasy
that you've created on your own yes
again the image of the brain swinging
like a pendulum sense nonsense parallels
the scales of justice and the way harrow
staff and the lanterns all swing back
and forth also putnam psychiatric
hospital is a facility in the jeff
lemire comics where mark's father elias
interns him after mark witnessed the
nazi serial killer posing as a rabbi
witnessing this murder being the
traumatic event that causes d.i.d so as
hard as it was to watch a child abuse in
this episode definitely not as dark as
that would have been a clock appears on
the back wall just like the one in the
rec room hands also made of konshu's
staff shape with a crescent moon tip and
like that one this clock also does not
actually move but the ticking is still
going and it's now actually grown louder
so that each tick edits the shot to a
new frame right you're doing everything
and everything possible not to look
within and again my favorite set detail
about this is that this set in the
office is the same attic set from
harrow's compound in episode 2 painted
over white and back in that moment
steven said to layla oh my god
i'm going to die on an evil magician's
man cave yes cave i think they reused
that set and that same fear of death and
the cave trigger to decorate to this
representation of the altar's fear
within the duot now by the way i love
all the visual details that went into
tuaret her ears constantly wiggling
especially when she's a little nervous
her blue fingernail polish which is the
same color as the paint on her chest
scarab and this is awesome in the corner
mirror that is always behind her the vfx
artist always added her reflection even
showing her back when she turns such
great attention to detail here now she
says it's been a minute since we've had
a soul passing here which is a nod to
that rift between gods and man when
humans stopped believing in the egyptian
gods and so naturally fewer people's
souls over the millennia would see their
afterlife as this egyptian duot in
addition to the fun animation i just
love the characterization of this
hippopotamus brought to life by antonia
solep excuse me
okay
here we go
welcome yeah her nervous apologies the
way she licks her lips and then when she
tries to clear her throat it comes out
like a hippopotamus belch
she declares
welcome
gentle traveler
travelers
to the realm of the jewels
this is the afterlife the afterlife and
afterlife not the
afterlife
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist
like the ancestral plane oh just
gorgeous yes as i interpreted this
hospital is the subjective underworld of
the mcu in this case called the duat
much like the way t'challa and
killmonger's perceptions of the
ancestral plane took the forms of an
african savannah or an oakland apartment
and this also suggests that there are
countless mcu afterlives that all take
various forms one of them was likely the
soul stone way station that thanos was
transported to i'm going to talk about
this a lot more in future videos because
despite claiming not to connect too much
to the mcu moon knight just contributed
more mc world building than anything we
saw in hawkeye or the falcon the winter
soldier now also those lamps tilting the
hallway last episode to the sounds of a
creaky hull were indeed a sign that this
is all aboard a vessel as we have been
speculating ever since we saw that
sunken boat and gus's fish tank and of
course how egyptian mythology depicts
the underworld passage using similar
boat imagery i love how the sky of the
sun world is purple also reminiscent of
the ancestral plane when t'challa first
enters it frozen in the sand are past
guilty souls also kind of reminding us
of the scattered pruned figures of the
void the bow of this vote has a torah at
statue and a smaller one is aboard the
rudder tuaret and stephen explain that
they are headed toward the aru the field
of reeds the heavenly paradise from
egyptian mythology only accessible if
their hearts weight balances with the
feather of truth to where it pulls their
hearts from their chests another indiana
jones reference by the way temple of
doom there but their hearts are a white
stone maybe because disney plus does not
want a bloody pulsing organ but also
reflects how konchu is currently encased
in stone ushabti form but these scales
are held by anubis who in egyptian
mythology is the true purveyor of
justice standing before ahmet unlike
harrow's scales tattoo which shows
ahmet's croc heads holding the scales
mark suggests to kill the hippos steal
the boat but they head back inside to
try to balance their souls each room now
containing a dark memory from their past
kind of like the memory elevator of
inception but also a lot like in one
division another series that spends its
penultimate episode going down memory
lane we see the museum bathroom from
episode one and across the hall from
that steven's memory of rewinding the
stars in episode three with konchu that
room labeled treatment room this being
the traumatic moment they lost konchu
but the third room is actually labeled
with the qr code for the floor map and
when you scan this it actually takes you
to the comic issue of moon knight number
one of 1980 the first solo issue of the
moon knight character showing his origin
story with bushmen literally the floor
map of this hospital is mark's origin
story mark brushes off the memory of him
standing on that street outside his
mother shiba but steven knows only their
darkest's most unresolved moments are
being kept here and then the cafeteria
remarks victims from his time as
kanchu's avatar all of their canopic
jars on the tables in front of them they
were criminals murderers predators the
worst of the worst yeah thankfully the
camera is not on mark when he says
predators because i would not want to be
the actor labeled predator in this
episode or ever but also among these
victims is randall whom mark does still
feel guilt for killing it's interesting
how randall is able to move around
meaning that all of these other corpses
are also mobile which is creepy to think
how they're all just sitting here
listening waiting to make their move
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video let's talk about your mental
health and therapy we get our cars
serviced to prevent bigger issues down
the road you go to the dentist to have
good dental health so going to therapy
is a lot like that it's routine
maintenance for your mental and
emotional wellness you're investing in
yourself to keep your mind healthy well
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't even have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to you just fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and then you get matched
with the therapist in under 48 hours
then you schedule secure video and phone
sessions plus you can exchange unlimited
messages and everything you share is
completely confidential several new
rockstar staff members have used better
help and loved how convenient it was one
person even helped get some of their
family members signed up for the service
you can request a new therapist at no
additional charge any time so many
people use better help that they are
currently recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states so join the
2 million plus people who have taken
charge of their mental health with
better health get ten percent off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash new rockstars for 10 off
your first month steven follows roro to
the memory of the barbecue with her
mother wendy and their father elias come
check out my drawing he drew the fish
with only one fin mark be nice to your
little brother yeah i love the blocking
with oscar isaac and carlos sanchez who
plays young mark incredible performances
from both of them this episode as they
both turned to look back at the mom and
then back of their brother sinked
randall's drawing of the fish of course
reflects gus's nemo finn and the way
poor randall will end up unable to swim
similar to how gus perished outside of
steven's memory as steven woke up to him
just replaced young mark says ladies
gators
a wild crocodile showing the origin of
steven's sign off with his mum he always
said that to her but never heard her
loving response and of course sets up
mark's showdown with the croc mouth of
onit mark and randall venture into a
cave and stephen follows stepping on
poncho looking bird bones that could
explain why konju takes a skeletal form
in mark's eyes when in egyptology konchu
has a living bird head the brothers say
i'll be rotter though
can you hear that doctor ground i sure
do rosa
sounds to me like danger yes rosser is
the name of dr grant's young sidekick
toon buster being a movie that these
brothers must have watched together and
rorro being his nickname probably came
from rosser and him doing the british
accent is likely what inspired mark to
start doing that voice to escape his mom
as steven pushes into the flooding cave
the sounds of water also play over the
shots of mark in the psych ward but we
never see the boys inside of the cave
and we never see young mark escaping it
yes there are lots of rules about
filming child actors in water it's
generally not a safe thing to do but you
can also interpret this metaphorically
mark entered plato's allegory of the
cave and never came back out he never
reached your enlightenment he just
remained chained up in that cave only
able to perceive reality as deceptive
shadows on the wall but then mark enters
the memory of the shiva for his brother
now a shiva is a jewish funeral service
for a close family member and i really
love that they include the detail of the
mirror being covered in this green sheet
because it's customary to cover mirrors
in the shiva household so that the
mourners focus less on themselves and
solely on the deceased but this also
reminds us of mark's partially covered
mirror in his hotel room at the end of
episode 2 a shot that also prominently
featured his star of david necklace mark
tried to cover that mirror but the sheet
slid off throughout the series his
mirror reflection has been what's
haunting him everywhere now reflecting
how he's truly unable to mourn the
staircase that stephen goes up has
actually been seen in the closing
credits to every episode and now we know
why birthday after birthday it's a
powerful representation of the torment
that his mother put him through we start
with elias and mark blowing out the
candles together but framed behind them
in the middle is that wet bar with the
decanter of booze now steven goes up
again but just finds himself back on
that same floor impossible to escape the
cycle of abuse and now on this birthday
the decanter is in wendy's hand hey a
pro tip if someone is walking around
with a glass of booze in one hand and
the full bottle on the other just
waiting to refill it there is a problem
and poor teenage mark finally just has
to leave this house actually behind mark
in the scene is this poster showing
someone falling down a hole as this
whole episode shows mark and steven
doing descending deeper and deeper into
memory mark and stephen tumble on to the
dig site incident turns out going awol
in a fugue state gets you discharged
from the military didn't have a ton of
options after that so i went work for
hire for my old co bushman yes referring
to raul buschmann mark's mercenary
partner in the comics turned villain
responsible for the death of marlene's
archaeologist's father or in this case
laylah's father mark recounts how he
tried to help this dig team escape but
ended up getting shot himself and had to
crawl into the tomb of konchu now notice
how the moon overhead is now in its
waning crescent phase the crescent shape
meaning konshu's power is rising we can
also see this same phase of the lunar
cycle in the episode 5 credits which
have been changing episode episode so
mark nearly offs himself here as we saw
jake tried to do earlier with that
paperweight but konshu stops him
what a waste
huh now it's interesting you could
actually interpret everything that
happened to mark's life after this point
as the judgment journey of a man within
the moment of his suicide which uh by
the way my hot take for liam neeson in
the gray think about it konchu says
your mind
i feel it
fractured
broken
most fascinating
you
are a worthy candidate to serve me
during this time yes so khanshu didn't
possess mark in spite of his did but
actually preys on him because of it and
there's a really quick subtle shot here
as mark first drifts closer to death he
looks up at the statue and briefly we
see konchu's actual hand and staff
before that statue just a way of showing
how mark is already beginning to allow
that deity into his heart and mark
consents memorize
[Music]
yes the first and so far only time moon
knight has been spoken on this show
another parallel to one division episode
8 which ended with agatha saying wanda's
superhero moniker for the first time in
the mcu that makes you
the scarlet witch
i like how various colors flicker across
mark's face during this transformation
showing the supernatural power
inhabiting his flesh as well as giving
him this cool suit back on the deck
baboon scatter now baboons actually play
an important role during the duot
process carrying out tots duties as the
god of measurement as the heart is
weighed on scales baboons also guard the
gate of the underworld tuaret says fear
is spreading in the upper world
unbalanced souls are being judged to
condemn to the sands before their time
oh this is bad this is evil yes souls
plummet into the sand at an alarming
rate meaning harrow must have freed amit
from her ushabti and is now wreaking
havoc on the world i cannot wait to see
this judgment process upstairs because
ahmet is depicted as a ferocious
croc-headed beast with the front half of
a lion the back half of a hippo tawara
and konchu are about 10 feet tall but
could ahmet be like a freaking
bust-sized monster bouncing through the
streets of cairo eating anyone who
smells evil or is ahmed's judgment a
remo process that opens up purple
underworld portals beneath the feet of
rotten egg souls like veruca salt is
that what that poster behind teenage
mark was referring to whatever it is
it's gonna be wild they're able to
convince tawara to steer them back
toward osiris gate and stephen snaps at
mark if layla dies
that's on your head
it'll be all your fault no no no no no
you can't i won't do it i won't do it
you can't fight me yes steven
accidentally speaks wendy's torment
words and mark finds himself back in
harrow's office his face no longer
injured just even more evidence that the
altar in the first scene of this episode
was not mark or stephen here harrow asks
the core question of the series do you
think you created steven to hide
from all the awful things you feel
you've done in your life or do you think
steven created mark to punish the world
for what your mother did to you this
really is the chicken or the egg
argument of the series who created whom
how far back did this really go
ultimately i think we did start with
mark i just like how this show casts
just enough doubt on the reliability of
his perception and we return to the
awful day it begins with a close-up on
the table as mark swipes the action
figures of dr stephen grant and rosser
but really would these like the
tombstone poster truly exist as merch in
the mcu for a little seen knock-off
direct to vhs movie also considering
this is the same universe of actually
real ip as ned flanders and the simpsons
finding nemo in both avatars not to
mention on the other wall of this room
is the movie poster for the 1977 star
wars also on mark's side table are a
pair of nunchucks and a wooden scale
showing how even in this memory mark and
steven's souls are still being judged
and behind mark on the other side of
that room is the chicago cubs banner as
well as randall's fish drawing when we
clearly saw randall finishing coloring
in the fin as orange on the day of his
death and we see the moment that young
mark first creates the steven alter
bloody hell
look at the state of this place
best way out before mom sees it and
folks according to clinical research
this is how did manifests in patients
often a traumatic childhood memory in
this case we learned that it was mark
willing into existence an alter who did
not have to have this abusive woman as
his mother and might instead have a
mother that actually loves him steven
notices the tomb buster poster tagline
when danger is near steven grant has no
fear also in that poster you can see the
split bust of the aztec moon deity
koyashaki now side eyeing them but the
poster credits are filled with easter
eggs timely atlas studios timely atlas
being the original name of marvel comics
doug perlin is a merging of the moon
knight creators doug munch and don
perlin melissa russell is the wife of
writer jeremy slater dylan beck is the
assistant production coordinator on the
show wyatt and dylan curtis probably
related to the producer grant curtis
colleen strasellowitz is the wife of
nick peppin whose own name cameoed back
in episode 2. carmel benson is probably
related to director justin benson amy
stewart is a partner director aaron
morehead nor iqbal mulvey is married to
the writer sabird prusada and i assume
the other names are just loved ones for
other staff and crew wendy moves in to
abuse her son but again this must not
have been stephen at the moment of the
abuse otherwise he would have remembered
it so i truly do think that the alter
present for all those beatings really
could have been jake stephen returns to
harrow's office gracie's harrow's
diploma this thing just says graduate
diploma in psychology no university
listed no signature only that he
graduated in december 13 2011 yeah it's
a fake see if it makes another pop
culture reference it's so strange
a little haircut
a little silly tash there it's very
ned flanders yeah the visual totally
tracks but also ned flanders is known as
springfield's dogmatically faithful true
believer as harrow is for amit
hero arranges to call steven's mom hey
dylan yeah can you call mrs gray please
yes dylan is the name of steven's tour
guide date now coming back here as a
receptionist to this facility but steven
doesn't want the call go through because
he knows that there will be no one at
the other end of that call just as there
wasn't for any of his calls just the
dial tone
now no call was actually made here of
course this is just stephen finally
facing his own truth at wendy's spectre
shiva mark stands outside in front of
the watterson food and liquor anonymous
executive producer trevor waterson mark
walks off and collapses smacking his
yamaka but then cradles it
yes this violent act makes him see his
yamaka as his brother that he still
feels guilt for harming and for a second
it seems like he's looking directly into
steven's eyes but he's actually
reverting into a steven alter hey yeah
mum hey you all right yeah um
would you believe it
i am totally lost again i don't know
where i am if you look closely his phone
screen shows that he is not actually on
a call mark confirms this happened two
months prior as mom's death and shiva
was that inside an incident behind his
recent struggle to keep stephen at bay
stephen helps mark start to forgive
himself it wasn't your fault
and upon this we return to another
upside down overhead shot matching
steven entering the museum in episode 2
as they joined tuaret back on the deck
as they approached the gates of osiris
but the scales still have not balanced
so mark's past victims crawl up from the
sand mark punches one of their faces off
but he's still pushing back even
faceless steven grabs a rudder to knock
them off their balance then hits them
with that bat
[Music]
i prefer cricket yeah six is what you
yell when you've scored in qriket but
really just as steven did as a kid with
those spilled pencils it's left to
steven to clean up mark's messes steven
makes the ultimate sacrifice tackling
the last one down into the sand
stranding him in the duat bing bong
style all foreshadowed by that goddamn
kid and did it suck for you getting
rejected from the fields of reeds well
that doesn't make sense because i'm not
dead am i stevie
and so steven turns into a sand
sculpture his last word being mark and
his hand reaching out in the same
gesture imposed that crawly freezes
himself in i truly hope that steven
isn't gone forever like if the iniat or
any higher power rules that ahmet's
premature condemnation of all those
reigning souls was unjust it's totally
possible that stephen could be part of a
divine retraction and could definitely
rejoin his altars in the living world
and again i believe that jake lockley is
still in that psych ward and if tuaret
can make her case to osiris the best
warrior of these three alters can take
hero and ahmet to the mat but whether by
tragic coincidence or because mark no
longer needs his stephen alter to escape
his trauma those scales now finally
balance and mark has moved to the aru
it's an immediate and smooth transition
as if he was there the whole time just
waiting for that amber sunlight to beam
through those purple clouds now earlier
tawarit likened the underworld to the
ancestral plain and this field of reeds
definitely resembles a paradise where
t'challa's ancestors beckon him to join
them but with the sunlight and the tall
plants it also evokes the garden
thanos's pastoral retirement but
ultimately for mark this is not a
paradise it is hell because he knows he
does not belong here music we hear is
masaya del sol sung by manuel bonilla
and santiago stevenson a spanish hymn
sung at funerals in mexico and
throughout latin america maybe a nod to
oscar isaac's guatemalan and cuban
ancestry but the lyrics translate to
beyond the sun beyond the sun i have a
home home beautiful home meant to convey
how in your present life you might be
poor and lost but in heaven paradise
awaits unfortunately for mark it is not
the sun that he connects with it's the
moon actually just as the opening shot
of this episode cuts from something mark
feared to something he wanted an abusive
mother to an understanding mother the
closing shot now cuts the same way from
the sunny field of reeds something he
doesn't want to the closing title card
that same field of breeds but with the
correct crescent moon shape overseeing
it all you can follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos following the
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you